and I know that you have dealt with
celiac disease and it's real right MH
like it's real I I don't think people
quite understand you know some people
are like oh I I don't eat gluten and
people like oh gosh gluten you know here
we go with the gluten thing and I'm like
I first of all I'll say when I don't
have gluten and I don't have dairy I
feel significantly better significantly
so tell me tell me exactly what it does
to you and what happens when you do take
things you're not supposed to take or
eat okay well I found out on the when I
was in Texas doing the thing about
football um I got really really really
sick Connie and I would go out and eat
every night and it was just you know
whatever was amazing which is everything
here and I just started to get like
really bad stomach pains like almost
like I feel like I might know what being
shot feels like whoa like I would have
pills pain pills that I mean I'd be
driving and I would be writhing in pain
on the side of a road for sometimes an
hour um and it was never consistent and
then I started dropping a ton of weight
and I had this belly sleeping 14 hours a
day still didn't feel like I was
sleeping and then the really freaky
thing was I couldn't walk up a flight of
stairs I was so out of out of
breath so I finally went to the doctor
and he gave me a blood test and I had
absolutely no B
vitamin I was so anemic uh I almost
needed I was like
0.1 away from needing a blood
transfusion no vitamin D anything so it
almost it looked virtually like I was
anorexic you know what I mean did he ask
you that yeah he asked me all the
questions I mean again to I'm like
really thin I'm like you don't
understand how much I eat and it just
like I don't know what's going on so he
tested me for a million different things
and I had already kind of self-
diagnosed at that point when I was
younger because I always had tummy
issues and hadn't eaten like anything
Carby I always did really well on that
so I was just like you know would you
just test me for celiac he's like you're
supposed to be born with that if you
were born with it you'd be 4 foot2 and
it's just an old school way of thinking
and I'm like just listen you're already
testing me for Ms and all this other
you know um sure enough the thing
that came back positive was Celiac and
you have to go to a gastroenter it is a
whole thing because you're like more
susceptible to like colon cancer and all
those things but yeah it's a real thing
and so it's an ultimately a malnutrition
disorder because it kills the Villi in
your intestines if you have Celiac and
you can't absorb
nutrients so this is why you feel or
felt the fat fatigue why you weren't
gaining weight why you weren't having
the strength to go up the stairs it was
because of this yes and what what did
you do how hard is it to get on a
specific diet and stick to it in the
beginning it was hard I mean it's it's
so easy now like everybody has a gluten
sensitivity or allergy or whatever and
like most places have
gluten-free you know Austin always
did even when I was first diagnosed they
had a bakery
um but it was it was the sauces I kept
messing up because I didn't realize that
it's like literally in every
sauce so that became kind of a you know
Touch and Go thing so it's really hard
for people to start on that but it's
just it's so easy now and sometimes the
stuff tastes better hey guys I'm doing
another live podcast downtown LA at the
Regent Theater and my special guest for
January 24th is Christ Ritter Breaking
Bad Jessica Jones this is going to be a
soldout event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited